this really is a Friday the 13th
Felicity Huffman will never forget today
she learned her fate in the college
bribery scandal yeah and our nischelle
Turner is outside the courthouse in
Boston with every detail Michelle what's
going on
yeah Brooke and Kevin it was intense in
there the air was thick I was inside the
courtroom when the judge announced her
decision felicity is going to prison
after a dramatic hearing felicity was
sentenced to 14 days in prison but
that's not all the 56 year old actress
will also have to pay a thirty thousand
dollar fine and perform 250 hours of
community service it was a devastating
afternoon for the couple Felicity and
her husband actor William H Macy both
cried inside the courtroom after the
sentence was handed down Macey comforted
his wife and rubbed her back the couple
looked defeated as they walked out of
court so what's next Felicity will have
six weeks to prepare for her 14 day
prison sentence she must turn herself in
by October 25th so where will she served
time for her team is pushing for a
low-security federal institution in
Dublin California its 347 miles north of
Los Angeles and about a five-hour drive
but ultimately that decision where she
goes is up to the Bureau of Prisons
Prison consultant John doc Fuller who is
the author of a day in prison expects
that Felicity will be assigned duties
won't be allowed makeup and the new
routine nerve-racking inmates tend to
lose weight they become more
health-conscious they begin exercising
to offset the stress of incarceration
shortly after the sentencing Felicity
released a statement apologizing for
what you did and saying quote I can
promise you that in the months and years
to come that I will try and live a more
honest life prosecutors argue that
Felicity lied and sent her daughter's
fraudulent SAT scores to schools all
over the country to get admission for
her daughter calling it intentional
criminal conduct
it's interesting to point out that
Felicity's attorney made what could have
been a dig at Lauri Lachlan and her
cakes arguing that Felicity did not
enlist her daughter's participation like
some other defendants and Lori and her
husband are up next to face the music
they each face up to 40 years in prison
they have a status hearing on October
2nd
[Music]